ils ont foulé le tapis rouge ces jeunes
trappistes faisait partie des finalistes
du concours toi même tu filmes initiée
par youtube avec laure de vidéos ils ont
voulu parler des personnes homosexuelles
et de la ville de trappes
les homosexuels sont reste des personnes
normales
ils sont comme nous tu ce 10ème les
garçons ils aiment les filles quoi dans
notre entourage je pense à tout
certaines personnes et on sait que quand
c'est pas facile d'en parler et on a
touché certaines personnes dans notre
film on a voulu montrer les préjugés sur
la ville de trappes tout ce que les
médias en fait 10 sur la ville de
trappes 90 secondes pour s'exprimer
autour de la fraternité avec plusieurs
mois de travail
l'issue a eu lieu hier avec la remise
des prix par le jury composé notamment
du trappistes jamel debbouze internet et
est quelque chose qu'on ne peut
expliquer suivre un dernier tir centre
interdites et cette année les jeunes de
trappes repartent bredouilles de nantes
la jolie obtient deux prix dont celui de
la jeunesse commis par la ministre de
l'éducation najat vallaud belkacem
on l'a trahie elle a réfléchi pendant
très longtemps pour l'histoire
mercredi on mérite bien mais on est
content on est content j'étais très très
content de pouvoir gagner ce prime pour
moi c'est énorme en fait et moi je
pensais pas que j'allais gagner un prix
parce qu'elle avait d'autres vidéos qui
était vraiment bien et le concours sera
à nouveau organisé l'an prochain les
trappistes veulent y participer cette
année 800 jeunes invités à la
réalisation